it seems that matter is basically mass
and energy swirling around each other
the same could be said for solar systems
is it possible our solar system as an
atom or the Milky Way's a molecule that
was a deep thought
100 million 110 years ago people as we
started probing the structure of the
atom we looked at and say oh there's a
nucleus there's electrons and they're
orbiting around maybe that's just a mean
but there are no cats and there's no
cows and farms and buildings when we
come back I will give the answer to why
atoms are not solar systems you're
listening to start talking out basically
there really is our solar system an atom
or as the milky way of molecules yeah
and there's a great questions about deep
questions that were asked about 120
years ago 120 years late and risking
this played around with the sheesh first
reached Boston saying you have the date
for that so here's the problem the
problem when we discovered atoms and
that there's a nucleus and electrons is
a hey that looks like a solar system
yeah I wonder if inside an atom there's
yet another atom and another atom if
there's an episode of Mork and Mindy but
yeah it turns out that the laws of
physics that describe what goes on in a
solar system are different from the laws
of physics that describe it what goes on
in an atom and so the conduct of matter
and energy is completely different in
these two regimes really and because of
it as you mentioned before the break
know within atoms you don't have cats
you know right you don't have yeah this
Alden board but this stuff that does not
happen inside of atoms right that
happens macroscopically so the
microscopic world and macroscopic so the
democratically the macroscopic world
responds to what we call classical
physics right and the microscopic world
responds to quantum physics quantum
physics actually applies to the whole
universe but a large enough scale it
looks like classical physics and
equations are easier so we just use it
right use those modes to describe it so
no it's not just the Russian egg the
Russian dolls the nest thing that's left
it oh that's how you say that yeah Mike
feels very good says woo and I should go
to Moscow
know what they'll just give the dolls so
no it's just not that but we had a
really cool philosophical revelation
there's no life inside of an atom or
molecule none that we know of or that we
we've ever defined as such right correct